>> ACTION.
>> TONIGHT ON
THE CYCLE 16 FINALE,
ONE LUCKY GIRL WILL BECOME
A COVERGIRL, AN IMG MODEL,
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GRACE THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE".
>> THIS IS A GIRL
WHO WANTS A SHOT.
>> LAST WEEK,
HANNAH WAS ELIMINATED...
>> THANKS, TYRA.
>> LEAVING TWO GIRLS LEFT
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> OOH. THAT'S REALLY SEXY.
>> WILL IT BE BRITTANI,
THE GIRL FROM HUMBLE BEGINNINGS
IN A TRAILER PARK,
WHO CONSISTENTLY IMPRESSED
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
AND ON THE RUNWAY,
BUT WHO HIT A SPEED BUMP
ALONG THE WAY?
>> I DON'T (bleep) CARE
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME.
>> YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
THE CLIENT, AND YOU HAVE TO
RESPECT YOURSELF.
>> (hyperventilating) I'M HAVING
A PANIC ATTACK.
I CAN'T REALLY TALK.
>> OR WILL IT BE MOLLY...
>> YES.
>> THE GIRL WHO TAKES
STUNNING PHOTOS AND WHOSE
LOVING ADOPTIVE PARENTS
SUPPORTED HER
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY...
>> LET'S JUST DO THIS.
>> BUT WHOSE ATTITUDE
HAS OFTEN DISTRACTED
FROM HER TOP MODEL POTENTIAL?
>> NO, IT'S NOT (bleep) OKAY.
>> WITH COMPETITION
THIS FIERCE,
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
FIND OUT TONIGHT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH... JEEZ.
>> (inhales sharply)
I CAN'T CONTAIN MY JOY
ANY LONGER.
BRITTANI AND MOLLY ARE
THE TOP TWO FINALISTS,
AND I'M STOKED.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I GREW UP WITH MY MOM,
WHO WAS A SINGLE MOTHER.
MY MOM HAVING
HAVING PANIC/ANXIETY DISORDER,
GROWING UP,
IT DID SHAPE ME AS A PERSON.
WE WERE ON WELFARE FOR, LIKE,
THE FIRST EIGHT YEARS
OF MY LIFE.
EVERYBODY BACK HOME IS
GONNA BE SO SHOCKED.
AND MY MOM'S GONNA BE SO PROUD
OF ME.
I WANT THIS, AND I WILL WIN.
>> I CAN'T...
>> (bleep)
>> FOR MY PARENTS TO FIND OUT
THAT I'M THE TOP (bleep) TWO.
>> OH, MY GOD. I KNOW.
...THINKING ABOUT THAT,
AND IT JUST MADE ME WANT TO CRY.
>> THEY'RE GONNA DIE.
MY MOM IS GOING TO DIE.
THIS HAS BEEN MY DREAM.
THIS HAS BEEN HER DREAM FOR ME
EVER SINCE WE STARTED
WATCHING THIS SHOW.
I'VE DEALT WITH
SO MANY THINGS IN MY LIFE.
I THINK BEING ADOPTED
GAVE ME SOME ABANDONMENT ISSUES.
I, UH, TOOK IT OUT
ON MY ADOPTIVE PARENTS.
I WOULD, YOU KNOW,
TEST BOUNDARIES WITH THEM
AND JUST GO OFF AND DO DRUGS
AND, YOU KNOW, NOT COME HOME.
I GAINED SO MUCH
FROM GOING TO REHAB
AND WAS SUCH A BETTER PERSON
AFTER COMING OUT OF IT.
THINGS CAN CHANGE.
THINGS CAN ALWAYS LOOK UP.
I'M LIVING PROOF OF THAT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH!
(singsongy) SO PRETTY!
>> "ROMANTIC BOHEMIAN."
I NEVER REALIZED HOW, LIKE,
HIGH MY CHEEKBONES WERE
UNTIL I CAME HERE.
THIS IS MY THIRD BEST PHOTO
IN A ROW.
IT'S PRETTY AWESOME,
ESPECIALLY, YOU KNOW,
AT THIS POINT IN THE GAME,
TO BE DOING SO WELL.
BRITTANI'S DEFINITELY
TOUGH COMPETITION.
SHE'S NOT AS GOOD AS ME
IN PHOTO SHOOTS,
BUT SHE'S REALLY, REALLY GOOD
IN RUNWAY
AND SHE'S GOT A FIERCE LOOK.
BUT NO ONE IS GONNA WANT YOU
AS A RUNWAY MODEL
IF YOU TAKE A (bleep) PICTURE
ON THE END OF THE RUNWAY.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE
WE'RE TOP TWO.
>> WE'RE THE ONLY TWO LEFT
IN HERE.
>> YEAH, IT'S A NICE FEELING.
ONE SIDE OF MOLLY'S
KIND OF, LIKE,
"OKAY, I HAVE THIS IN THE BAG.
I ALWAYS TAKE
REALLY GOOD SHOTS."
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I THINK SHE'S
A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS
JUST BECAUSE I AM
MORE HIGH FASHION THAN HER.
I DEFINITELY THINK THAT
THAT COULD PLAY IN MY ADVANTAGE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> ♪ TYRA MAIL, OH! ♪
>> (chuckles)
>> UGH.
UGH.
"SAHEL, KHAFIF, ZOULNAH."
I HOPE THAT'S NOT THE WORDS
WE HAVE TO USE
IN OUR COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
I THINK I'D MAKE
A GREAT COVERGIRL.
THE ONLY TIME I WAS
EVER IN THE BOTTOM TWO IS
BECAUSE OF THAT WHOLE BAD THING
THAT HAPPENED.
I JUST WANT SOMEONE
THAT DESERVES IT.
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
>> YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
THE CLIENT, AND YOU HAVE TO
RESPECT YOURSELF.
>> (hyperventilating) I'M HAVING
A PANIC ATTACK.
I CAN'T REALLY TALK.
AND NOW SHE'S, LIKE, "LISTEN.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU
AS THE PERSON ON THE INSIDE."
>> THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
TO SHOW THAT
THAT STRENGTH ON THE INSIDE
CAN BE CONSISTENT
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY.
>> THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE OF WHO I AM
ON THE INSIDE,
AND THAT MEANS EVERYTHING TO ME.
(sighs)
>> I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT THE COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
LIKE, I CAN BE MYSELF AND--
BUT I...
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M GONNA DO
WITH, LIKE, AH! YAY!
IN ORDER TO GET
A REALLY GOOD COMMERCIAL,
I KINDA HAVE TO ACT
A LITTLE BIT LIKE SOMEONE ELSE.
GOOD NIGHT, HO.
>> GOOD NIGHT, BEEYOTCH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MOLLY AND I ARRIVE
AT THIS BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY CLUB,
AND IVAN BART FROM IMG
IS THERE.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I WANT TO SPEAK
TO YOU INDIVIDUALLY
AND GET TO KNOW YOU
SO THAT I CAN GO BACK TO IMG
AND FEEL VERY CONFIDENT
WITH THE PERSON
THAT WINS THIS COMPETITION.
>> AWESOME.
IT'S NERVE-RACKING
TO MEET WITH IVAN.
HE'S THE VICE PRESIDENT OF IMG.
HE CAN MAKE OR BREAK A MODEL.
>> SO, MOLLY,
WHEN DID YOU DECIDE
THAT YOU WANTED TO MODEL?
>> I WAS ABOUT 12 YEARS OLD.
I HAD GAP TEETH
AND A BOWL HAIRCUT.
SO I DEFINITELY
DID NOT LOOK LIKE A MODEL,
BUT I WANTED TO DO IT ANYWAY.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE, LIKE,
A MUSE FOR A DESIGNER.
>> SO CAN I TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR BOOK...
>> YES, PLEASE.
>> AND SEE SOME OF THE STUFF
THAT YOU'VE DONE HERE?
>> SURE.
>> MOLLY IS AN AMAZING MODEL
IN PHOTOGRAPHS.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT SOMETHING HAPPENS
WITH THE HAIR, THE MAKEUP,
AND THE MAGIC.
>> I WAS REALLY EXCITED
TO GET TO MEET IVAN BART
ONE-ON-ONE.
THIS IS KIND OF MY CHANCE
TO ACTUALLY SHOW HIM
WHAT I'M CAPABLE OF.
>> IF I WAS GONNA SAY
THAT YOU NEEDED TO MOVE
TO MILAN
FOR SIX MONTHS,
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I WOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT
BECAUSE IT'S MY DREAM.
I MEAN, I'VE NEVER BEEN...
(clears throat) AWAY FROM HOME
FOR MORE THAN A WEEK,
AND SO FAR I'M DOING FINE.
I'VE BEEN AWAY FROM HOME
FOR ALMOST TWO MONTHS NOW.
MY FAMILY IS ALWAYS
GONNA BE THERE,
AND THAT'S WHAT MY MOM SAYS.
"HOME IS ALWAYS HERE.
YOUR OPPORTUNITIES ARE NOT."
>> BRITTANI--
SHE HAS A BEAUTIFUL FACE.
SHE HAS A WONDERFUL ATTITUDE.
GOOD LUCK, OKAY?
>> THANK YOU.
>> I'M VERY EXCITED TO SEE
BRITTANI DO THE RUNWAY.
I HEARD THAT'S HER STRONG POINT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE TWO COME WALKING IN.
HOW DO YOU GUYS FEEL RIGHT NOW?
FINAL TWO, MY GOSH.
>> AAH!
>> MM-HMM.
>> AWESOME, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> WE ARE
AT THE BELDI COUNTRY CLUB
FOR A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL
AND PRINT AD.
YOU'LL BE SHOOTING
WITH A WELL-KNOWN
ITALIAN PHOTOGRAPHER--
PIERPAOLO FERRARI.
AND ONE OF THE PHOTOS
THAT YOU SHOOT TODAY
WILL BECOME A NATIONAL PRINT AD
FOR WHOEVER WINS
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THE PRODUCT THAT WE'RE FEATURING
IN BOTH SHOOTS IS COVERGIRL'S
LipPerfection LIPCOLOR.
IT COMES IN 44 SHADES,
WHICH IS AMAZING.
THAT MEANS WE'RE GONNA FIND
A SHADE THAT'S PERFECT FOR YOU,
AND IT WILL ALLOW
YOUR TRUE PERSONALITY
TO COME THROUGH.
I'LL BE DIRECTING YOU
IN TODAY'S COMMERCIAL,
AND WE'RE GONNA BE SHOOTING IT
IN A TRUE COVERGIRL STYLE,
ON A WHITE SITE.
BUT WE'LL BE SHOOTING YOU
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH
THREE DIFFERENT CAMERA ANGLES.
SO YOU NEED TO DELIVER
IN EVERY DIRECTION.
AND THEN YOU KNOW
THERE'S A SCRIPT YOU'VE
GOTTA PROBABLY LEARN, RIGHT?
BUT I WILL HAVE A TELEPROMPTER
ON THE CENTER CAMERA ONLY.
YOU EXCITED?
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO HAIR
AND MAKEUP'S BACK THERE,
AND I'LL MEET YOU IN A SECOND.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M MOST NERVOUS
ABOUT THE COVERGIRL DAY
BECAUSE I'M NOT REALLY BIG
ON DOING COMMERCIALS,
AND I REALLY SUCKED
AT THE FIERCE ROAST THING
AND THE "INSIDER" THING.
SO EVERY TIME I SPEAK
IN FRONT OF A CAMERA,
IT'S JUST NOT GOOD.
>> SO DID YOU SEE
THE COLLECTIONS FOR YOU?
IT'S ALL--
>> SPELLBOUND.
THE COVERGIRL PRODUCT
THAT WE'RE SELLING IS
THE COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
IT NOT ONLY GIVES YOU
AWESOME COLOR.
IT MAKES YOUR LIPS
REALLY NICE AND SOFT.
"IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
HOW PERFECT.
NEW LipPerfection
IN 44 LIP-PERFECTING SHADES.
>> OH, MY GOD. THAT WAS SO GOOD.
>> WAS IT?
>> IT WAS JUST NATURAL.
>> OH, THIS IS GREAT.
YOU KNOW, I'M SO HAPPY.
>> "THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
IT DOESN'T JUST GIVE YOU
BEAUTIFUL COLOR NOW,
IT GIVES YOU BEAUTIFUL LIPS
IN SEVEN DAYS.
>> ALL RIGHT, BRITTANI, SO YOU
JUST GAVE ME A WHOLE SCRIPT.
YOU R--GAVE ME
ONE LINE AFTER ANOTHER.
SO WE JUST HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO KIND OF BRING YOU
INTO IT A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT ARE YOU
REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT?
>> DAMN IT. NOW I'M CRYING.
(chuckles)
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO CRY.
>> I THINK OVERALL, I WOULD
BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE STRESS
A LOT BETTER THAN SHE COULD.
SHE'S YOUNGER.
SHE'S GOT SOME ANXIETY ISSUES.
SO I THINK, UM,
I'M JUST AT A BETTER PLACE
IN MY LIFE TO BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH ALL THIS.
>> WE'RE SHOOTING, LIKE,
A DYNAMIC COMMERCIAL.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS COVERGIRL.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS BE MOLLY
FOR ME.
>> I KNOW THEY SAY
TO LET MY PERSONALITY SHINE,
BUT I'M REALLY FEELING
KINDA NERVOUS BEFORE THIS.
>> VERY QUIET. ROLLING.
(beep)
>> AND REMEMBER,
BEFORE I CALL "ACTION,"
YOU'RE ALREADY SMILING.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU'RE A COVERGIRL.
AND ACTION.
>> UNDENIABLY COLORFUL,
SERIOUSLY SMOOTH,
AND IN EXCELLENT CONDITION--
THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
>> HEY, MOLLY.
MAKE YOURSELF FEEL
THAT YOU CAN MOVE IN THIS SPACE.
>> I JUST DON'T WANT
TO BE LIKE...
>> TRUST. YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
YOU LOOK--EVEN WHEN YOU BRING
YOUR HANDS UP AND DO THAT,
WE SEE THOSE CUFFS,
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL MOMENT.
(beep)
>> ACTION.
>> THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
I THINK I GOT IN MY OWN WAY
A LITTLE BIT.
I JUST--I'M SELF-CONSCIOUS
SOMETIMES, AND I-I JUST TOTALLY
FELT LIKE AN IDIOT OUT THERE.
>> NOW THE ONLY THING
THAT YOU'RE DOING--
IT'S
VERYMETHODICAL.
>> I JUST DON'T--
I DON'T TALK WITH MY HANDS
A LOT, SO I'M LIKE, HAVING--
I DON'T WANT TO BE LIKE...
>> WELL, IF YOU DON'T TALK
WITH YOUR HANDS,
DON'T TALK WITH YOUR HANDS.
>> BUT THEN I'M JUST
GONNA BE LIKE THAT.
OKAY.
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO BE YOU.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THAT'S WHAT MAKES
A COVERGIRL A COVERGIRL.
>> RICH COLOR ROCKS YOUR LIPS.
IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
HOW PERFECT.
>> MOLLY,
THAT WAS MUCH MORE YOU.
>> MM-HMM.
>> LIKE, THE FIRST LINE--
I BELIEVED IT.
>> OKAY.
>> MOLLY WAS JUST SO CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING HERSELF
VERSUS A MODEL
AND FINDING A WAY
TO MAKE THE TWO MEET,
THAT SHE FORGOT AND LOST
ALL OF HER CHARM.
>> I'M JUST READY
TO GET IT OVER WITH.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS,
AND I JUST, LIKE, I KNOW
I HAVE TO DO WELL WITH THIS
BECAUSE IF ONE OF US
CAN PULL AHEAD OF THE OTHER,
THAT GIVES US A HUGE HEAD UP.
(beep)
>> AND ACTION.
>> IN A SINGLE STROKE,
RICH COLOR ROCKS YOUR LIPS.
IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
HOW PERFECT!
>> I THINK YOU'RE GOING
A LITTLE BACK TO WHERE YOU WERE
EARLIER IN THE DAY.
>> TOO FAST?
>> IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
RATTLING OFF A LAUNDRY LIST.
>> OKAY. I JUST NEED
TO SLOW DOWN,
AND IT WILL TOTALLY BE BETTER.
I'M SO STRESSED OUT
AND SO OVERWHELMED HERE.
>> ACTION.
>> UNDEN--UGH. UNDENIABLY--
>> OKAY.
LET'S START THAT CLEAN AGAIN.
>> START FREAKING OUT,
I'M GONNA HAVE A PANIC ATTACK.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> (sniffles)
>> I'M REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT
WHETHER BRITTANI'S
GOT THE CONFIDENCE
TO KIND OF FLIP THROUGH
AND DELIVER A COMMERCIAL
THAT'S TRULY GENUINE.
>> I THINK YOU'RE GOING
A LITTLE BACK TO WHERE YOU WERE
EARLIER IN THE DAY.
>> TOO FAST?
>> IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
RATTLING OFF A LAUNDRY LIST.
>> OKAY.
>> PRETEND YOU'RE, LIKE,
YOU'RE TALKING
TO YOUR THREE BEST FRIENDS.
>> I AM A LITTLE FREAKED OUT,
BUT IF I LET MY PERSONALITY
SHINE THROUGH,
I KNOW THAT I CAN DO THIS.
>> ACTION.
>> UNDENIABLY COLORFUL,
SERIOUSLY SMOOTH,
AND IN EXCELLENT CONDITION--
THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
>> THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
>> HA!
>> WHAT I LOVE IS
WHEN YOU DECIDE THAT
YOU'RE GONNA FLICK A SWITCH ON,
IT'S JUST ON.
>> COOL.
>> BRITTANI DELIVERED
A PERFORMANCE
THAT WAS QUIRKY, IT WAS FUN.
SHE WAS JUST
VERY, VERY COMFORTABLE THERE.
>> HI, MOLLY. NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> HI. NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> I'M PIERPAOLO.
>> HI.
>> WELCOME.
>> MY COMMERCIAL
WASN'T WHAT I WANTED IT TO BE,
BUT I KNOW I CAN TAKE
REALLY GOOD PICTURES,
AND IT'S A THING
THAT'S IN ALL THE MAGAZINES
THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE SEE.
>> OPEN A LITTLE BIT MORE
YOUR EYES.
OKAY, YES. OKAY.
WOW.
FOR A BEAUTY SHOT, UH,
MOLLY WAS PERFECT.
SHE GOT BEAUTIFUL MOUTH,
VERY BRIGHT EYE.
BRAVA, MOLLY!
MM-HMM.
NICE.
I WANT YOU NOT SWEET,
BUT STRONG.
>> COVERGIRL IS
TAKING IT UP A NOTCH.
THEY'RE NOT JUST
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR ANYMORE.
THEY'RE THE EDGY, FUN GIRL,
AND I REALLY THINK
THAT I COULD DO WELL WITH THAT.
>> OPEN YOUR MOUTH
A LITTLE BIT.
YES, LIKE THAT. NICE.
BRITTANI--SHE LOOK
A LITTLE BIT LIKE
THE MODELS IN THE PAST,
AND MAYBE BECAUSE THE HAIR
ARE A LITTLE BIT STRONGER/
I LIKE THAT KIND OF ATTITUDE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BELLISSIMA.
>> IT WAS SO FUN
WORKING WITH YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HOW'D EVERYTHING GO?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
MY COMMERCIAL WASN'T THAT GREAT.
>> I'M SURE YOU COULDN'T HAVE
DONE THAT BAD.
>> I DID PRETTY BAD, I THINK.
>> I'M REALLY GLAD
THAT MOLLY DIDN'T DO WELL TODAY
AND THAT SHE'S
KINDA DOWN IN THE DUMPS,
'CAUSE THAT COULD AFFECT HER
THE REST OF THE WEEK,
AND IF THAT HAPPENS,
I COULD--I COULD WIN.
>> MM.
>> YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA KILL IT
AT OUR ITALIAN "VOGUE" SHOOT.
>> YEAH.
IF I DON'T DO MY BEST
IN EVERY SINGLE THING,
THEN THERE'S A CHANCE
OF ME NOT WINNING,
SO IT'S DEFINITELY, UM,
A HUGE PRESSURE.
>> AH!
WE ARRIVE AT THIS AMAZING HOUSE.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
THERE'S, LIKE, A HUNDRED ROOMS.
IT'S, LIKE, A PALACE.
>> HI.
>> HELLO.
>> HI, GIRLS.
>> AND WE MEET WITH PAOLO AGAIN
AND VALENTINA SERRA,
THE STYLIST FROM "VOGUE ITALIA."
>> TODAY WE ARE SHOOTING
THE COVER AND THE FASHION SPREAD
FOR "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU GIRLS
WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AND WILL HAVE THIS PHOTO
PUBLISHED FOR THE WORLD TO SEE,
SO GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO STRONG ENERGY.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SHOOT.
>> COOL.
>> OKAY, COOL.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> GOOD.
>> I ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
ONE OF THE GIRLS
IN THE MAGAZINE,
ON THE PAGES
THAT I'M RIPPING OUT
AND PUTTING ALL OVER MY WALLS.
IF I CAN NAIL THIS,
THIS COULD ACTUALLY RUN
IN "BEAUTY IN VOGUE."
>> YES, TOUCH THE MIRROR
SUPER SOFTLY.
>> I'M JUST REALLY EMBRACING
THE INNER MODEL
THAT THEY KEEP TRYING
TO GET ME TO DO
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO BE POSE-Y.
JUST LETTING ME DO ME.
>> YES, BRAVA, BRITTANI.
>> BRITTANI, UH,
WAS VERY, VERY PROFESSIONAL.
>> YEAH, SHE ENJOY
WHEN SHE'S--SHE'S WORKING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> REALLY?
>> YEP. OF COURSE.
>> MOLLY'S CRANKY, LIKE ALWAYS.
SHE WAS JUST REALLY COLD
AND SHE WAS HUNGRY.
SO SHE'S DEFINITELY
NOT ON HER HIGHEST LEVEL,
AND I THINK IT'S
'CAUSE SHE DIDN'T DO SO WELL
YESTERDAY AT COVERGIRL.
>> MOLLY, WHEN YOU ARE READY,
I'M READY.
>> I AM ALWAYS LAST
EVERY SINGLE PHOTO SHOOT,
I SWEAR,
AND IT'S FREEZING COLD,
AND WE'RE GETTING PUT IN, LIKE,
LITTLE LINGERIE THINGS,
SITTING ON A STONE FLOOR.
IT'S JUST ANNOYING.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> PLEASE DON'T LOSE ENERGY.
>> YES.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE SAD, YOU KNOW?
>> (voice breaks) I'M
STRESSED OUT, AND, LIKE,
IF I DO ONE THING WRONG,
THEN I'M NOT GONNA WIN.
I'M GONNA BE SO PISSED
IF I DON'T WIN.
>> WE'RE ALMOST DONE.
DON'T GIVE UP.
MOLLY--AT A CERTAIN POINT,
SHE LOST A LITTLE BIT ENERGY.
>> YOU KNOW, EVEN IF YOU
FEEL TIRED OR IT'S COLD,
INSIDE OF YOU...
>> YOU HAVE TO BE HAPPY.
>> YOU NEED TO BE A-A VOLCANO.
RIGHT.
BRAVA! FINITO!FINISHED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AS FAR AS MOLLY AND I GO,
SHE'S A LOT MORE PESSIMISTIC,
AND I'M REALLY OPTIMISTIC,
AND ATTITUDE SHOWS A LOT
IN PHOTOGRAPHS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON ME RIGHT NOW,
BUT IT'S WORTH IT IF I WIN.
IT'S JUST BEEN
A LONG COUPLE MONTHS.
I'M GONNA BE SO PISSED
IF I DON'T WIN, AND I'M AFRAID
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (gasps) MOM!
HI, DAD!
IT WAS REALLY, REALLY AWESOME
TO COME HOME AND SEE
MY PARENTS ARE SITTING THERE.
>> HI, SWEETIE.
>> OH!
>> I'M SO GLAD TO SEE YOU.
>> I'M SO HAPPY THAT THEY CAME
ALL THIS WAY TO SUPPORT ME.
I WAS ADOPTED BY MY PARENTS
WHEN I WAS 4 DAYS OLD.
I'M SO GRATEFUL
FOR--FOR EVERYTHING
THAT THEY DO FOR ME
AND HOW SUPPORTIVE
THEY ARE OF ME.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> (crying) I'M OKAY.
I'M STRESSED OUT.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
>> I KNOW!
>> YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL!
>> I'M LOOKING OUT,
I'M LIKE, OKAY.
I KNOW MY MOM'S
NOT GONNA BE COMING
BECAUSE OF HER ANXIETY DISORDER
AND BECAUSE OF HER BACK SURGERY.
(crying) AND I'M JUST USED TO IT
BECAUSE MY MOM'S HAD
HER DISORDER, SO IT WAS HARD
FOR HER TO DO THINGS.
>> HEY. HOW ARE YOU?
SO GOOD TO MEET YOU.
>> HI. I'M GOOD. HOW ARE YOU?
>> SORRY YOUR MOM AND DAD
AREN'T HERE.
>> NO, IT'S OKAY.
(crying) I'M SO USED TO, LIKE,
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY,
AND THEN THERE'S NEVER
ANYBODY THERE.
(sniffles)
BUT I KNOW IT'S NOT HER FAULT
AND THAT SHE'D BE HERE
IF SHE COULD.
>> SO HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> MM, I FEEL OKAY.
I WAS A LITTLE STRESSED OUT
THIS MORNING.
>> REALLY? YOU?
>> YOU?
>> REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS,
YOU GUYS HAVE DONE
SOMETHING AMAZING.
IT'S GONNA BE LIFE-CHANGING
FOR BOTH OF YOU.
>> MY PARENTS ARE
REALLY, REALLY PROUD OF ME.
I USUALLY, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I GET UNCOMFORTABLE
AND ANGRY, I QUIT,
BUT IT'S A DREAM OF MINE
TO BE A TOP MODEL,
SO THEY'RE PROUD OF ME
FOR STICKING WITH IT
FOR SO LONG.
>> I'M GONNA GO DOWNSTAIRS
AND HAVE A SESSION.
>> YOUR PARENTS?
>> YEP. YEAH.
>> OH, GOOD.
REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> YEAH, IT WAS AWESOME
MEETING YOU GUYS.
WELL, I FIND OUT THAT I DO
ACTUALLY GET TO SEE MY MOM,
AND HER AND I TALK
VIA VIDEO CHAT,
AND IT'S REALLY AWESOME.
HEY, MOM.
>> Hi, Brittani.
I miss you.
>> I MISS YOU, TOO.
>> I wish that I could
be there for you, Brittani.
>> I REALLY KIND OF WANT
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT MY MOM
SINCE SHE'S DONE
SO MUCH FOR ME
AND SHE WORKS SO HARD,
AND SHE JUST HAD A BACK SURGERY.
SO SHE REALLY SHOULDN'T
BE DOING WHAT SHE DOES,
'CAUSE SHE'S ALWAYS ON THE,
LIKE, PEOPLE'S FLOORS SCRUBBING.
IF I MAKE IT THROUGH "TOP MODEL"
AND I WIN,
I WOULD JUST LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY, "LISTEN.
YOU DON'T NEED TO WORK ANYMORE.
I'LL JUST--
I'LL TAKE CARE OF IT."
>> Brittani,
I am very proud of you.
>> THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
TELL EVERYBODY I SAY HELLO.
I LOVE YOU.
>> I love you, too.
>> BYE.
>> Bye.
>> IT'S REALLY GREAT
TALKING TO MY MOM,
AND I FEEL LIKE
SHE REALLY BOOSTED
MY CONFIDENCE.
>> HOW'S YOUR FAMILY?
DID YOU HAVE A NICE TALK?
>> VERY GOOD.
>> GOOD.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU GUYS,
BOTH OF YOU.
YOU GUYS
OUGHT TO GET SOME SLEEP.
>> MM. THAT'S HOW WE...
>> YOU'RE SO FRENCH.
>> KISSING EVERYONE HERE.
IT'S SO WEIRD.
>> GOOD NIGHT.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW'S RUNWAY
WILL BE MODELING MANIA.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I'M EXCITED.
>> I'M EXCITED, TOO.
>> AFTER MOLLY'S
SEEN HER PARENTS,
HER ATTITUDE HAS IMPROVED.
LIKE, SHE'S NOT
IN A CRANKY MOOD ANYMORE.
SHE'S REALLY, REALLY HAPPY,
AND I'M LIKE,
I COULD'VE WON THIS EASILY.
NOW SHE'S HAPPY AGAIN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TODAY IS A HUGE, HUGE DAY.
>> BYE, MOROCCAN HOUSE.
>> IT'S PRETTY MUCH
GOING TO DICTATE
THE REST OF MY LIFE--
WHAT HAPPENS TODAY.
>> HEY!
WE'RE STANDING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE GRANADA PALACE,
WHICH WAS BUILT
IN THE 16th CENTURY.
>> (mouths word)
>> WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
A FIRST IN "TOP MODEL" HISTORY.
WE'RE DOING A SALON-STYLE
FASHION SHOW.
IT'S VERY INTIMATE.
LITERALLY, THE SHOW IS
GONNA GO FROM ONE ROOM
TO ANOTHER ROOM TO ANOTHER ROOM,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
SELL THE GARMENT.
NOW THE DESIGNER
FOR THE SALON-STYLE SHOW IS
THE INFLUENTIAL AND AVANT-GARDE
VIVIENNE WESTWOOD.
VIVIENNE WESTWOOD
ACTUALLY HAS THREE LINES,
AND THE THIRD ONE,
WHICH IS THE NEWEST,
IS CALLED
VIVIENNE WESTWOOD ANGLOMANIA.
IT'S YOUTH-ORIENTED,
IT'S HIP, IT'S CHIC,
AND IT TOTALLY CELEBRATES
BRITISH STYLE AND FASHION.
WE HAVE A FEW FAMILIAR FACES
WHO ARE GONNA BE
IN THE SHOW WITH YOU.
YOU GUYS, OF COURSE,
REMEMBER KASIA...
>> HI, GUYS.
>> AND WE'VE GOT ALEXANDRIA...
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> HI.
>> AND WE'VE GOT
OUR GIRL HANNAH.
>> HEY.
>> BUT WE CANNOT START THE SHOW
WITHOUT LAST CYCLE'S WINNER.
ANN FROM CYCLE 15 IS HERE.
>> AAH!
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI!
>> I JUST WANNA WISH YOU GUYS
GOOD LUCK.
YOU JUST HAVE TO CALM YOURSELF
AND JUST HAVE FUN WITH IT,
'CAUSE IT'S REALLY
JUST ABOUT HAVING FUN.
>> WE'RE READY?
>> BONJOUR.
>> I'M ROOTING FOR BRITTANI.
I FEEL LIKE
SHE REALLY DESERVES IT.
LIKE, SHE CAME
FROM A TRAILER PARK.
>> OH, THAT LOOKS SO COOL.
>> I'M GONNA HAVE TO ROOT
FOR MOLLY.
MOLLY'S HAD BEST PHOTO
MORE THAN BRITTANI.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING, MOLLY?
>> JUST READY TO DO THIS.
>> THIS ORANGE HALF OF ME IS
ROOTING FOR MOLLY.
THE PINK HALF IS
ROOTING FOR BRITTANI.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I DON'T LOOK LIKE
A FRENCH GIRL ANYMORE, DO I?
I EXPECT MYSELF
TO DO BETTER THAN MOLLY.
I ALREADY KNOW
THAT MY RUNWAY WALK
IS STRONGER THAN HERS.
IT'S JUST WHETHER OR NOT
I'M GONNA, LIKE, SLIP UP
OR DO SOMETHING STUPID
TO RUIN IT.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> SCARED BUT EXCITED, YOU KNOW.
>> YEAH.
>> HI.
>> OH, MY GOSH. HI!
IT'S WONDERFUL TO MEET YOU.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> I'M SO PROUD
OF YOUR BABY GIRL.
>> OH, WE'RE SO PROUD OF HER.
I WANTED CHILDREN
WITH A GOOD SELF-ESTEEM
AND A GOOD SENSE OF HUMOR.
THEY MAY NOT BE GREAT STUDENTS.
(laughs) THEY MAY NOT LOVE
BEING IN SCHOOL,
THEY MAY GET IN TROUBLE,
BUT SHE ALWAYS HAD
A GOOD SELF-ESTEEM
AND A GOOD SENSE OF HUMOR.
>> MOLLY AND I HAVE HAD...
A NICE CONVERSATION
ABOUT, LIKE, HOW MUCH
SHE APPRECIATES BOTH OF YOU...
>> OH, YOU'RE SO SWEET
TO SAY THAT.
>> AND YOUR UNCONDITIONAL LOVE.
>> (crying) I CAN'T EVEN,
LIKE, TALK.
I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
Y'ALL HAVE DONE FOR ME.
>> I KNOW THAT.
>> I KNOW.
>> STICKING THROUGH EVERYTHING
WITH ME, 'CAUSE I WAS A (bleep).
>> NO, YOU WEREN'T.
>> WHOA! YOU GOT HER
TO ADMIT THAT? THANK YOU.
>> ONCE I TURNED ABOUT 12, 13,
I STARTED GETTING ANGRY.
I JUST WAS SUPER DEPRESSED
AND CRYING A LOT.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I'M NOT SO SAD ANYMORE.
DEFINITELY ME GETTING THIS FAR
IN THE COMPETITION--
IT'S KIND OF, LIKE,
PAYING THEM BACK FOR EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'VE GIVEN ME.
YOU KNOW, I'M TRYING
TO MAKE THEM PROUD.
>> DO YOUR THING.
AND WHEN YOU POSE ON THAT THING,
YOU GIVE ME POSES,
BEAUTIFUL ART.
YES.
>> LEAVE A MEAN STARE.
>> (laughs) MEAN STARE.
>> OKAY. BYE.
>> FIERCE.
>> BYE, TYRA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LOOK AT HER. CHAKA KHAN.
(laughs)
HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD. HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
SO HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
MOLLY'S PARENTS ARE HERE,
YOUR MOM'S NOT.
>> IT'S OKAY 'CAUSE I KIND OF
EXPECTED THAT TO HAPPEN,
'CAUSE I KNEW MY MOM--
WITH HER ANXIETY...
>> YEAH.
>> AND THEN SHE HAD
HER BACK SURGERY, SO...
>> SO THAT'S GOOD
AND THAT'S THE STRENGTH...
>> YEAH.
>> THAT THIS INDUSTRY NEEDS
IS THAT... (inhales deeply)
>> I REALLY THINK I NEED THIS
MORE THAN MOLLY DOES,
'CAUSE I CAN'T DO IT
WITHOUT "TOP MODEL."
MOLLY'S PARENTS HAVE
ALREADY AGREED TO HELP HER.
>> GIMME SOME. OKAY, WORK IT.
>> I WILL. THANKS, TYRA.
♪♪♪♪♪
(indistinct conversations)
>> (cheering)
>> IS ANYBODY READY?
>> I'M FEELING REALLY NERVOUS
BEFORE THIS RUNWAY SHOW.
IF I DON'T REALLY KILL IT
IN THE RUNWAY, YOU KNOW,
I MIGHT NOT WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
AND--AND, YOU KNOW,
I DIDN'T COME HERE
TO GET RUNNER-UP.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THIS IS IT.
THIS IS PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST MOMENT IN MY LIFE.
THIS, RIGHT HERE, DETERMINES
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THIS.
I EITHER SIGN WITH IMG,
DO COVERGIRL,
OR I'M DEFINITELY GONNA HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE TRAILER PARK,
FIGURE EVERYTHING OUT
FROM THERE.
>> YOU CAN CUE THE MUSIC.
(electronic Moroccan music
playing)
>> HERE WE GO.
>> THERE SHE IS.
>> (cheering)
>> NICE.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> ANN, GO CHANGE.
THE THREE OF YOU GO
AND POSE TOGETHER.
AND SET. GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MOLLY LOOKS GREAT.
>> I DEFINITELY FEEL
LIKE A SUPERMODEL,
ALL DRESSED UP
AND--AND LOOKING PRETTY.
>> I CAN DEFINITELY SEE THIS
BEING MY LIFE.
I COULD DO THIS EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW, YEAH, I WILL GET
A LITTLE CRANKY, PROBABLY,
AND TIRED,
AND NEED A PEANUT BUTTER
AND JELLY SANDWICH,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I CAN DO IT.
>> OKAY, GO CHANGE, MOLLY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OKAY, BRITTANI, YOU READY?
>> LOOK AT--LOOK AT BRITTANI.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M SURPRISED I'M HERE.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
SHE LOOKS SO GOOD.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> NEVER WOULD I HAVE BEEN LIKE,
"I'M GONNA BE TOP TWO ON
'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.'"
COMING FROM A TRAILER PARK,
WHO WOULD THINK
OF SUCH A CRAZY THING?
I GET MY FIRST WALK DONE,
AND I'M RUNNING UP THE STAIRS.
>> HURRY UP. GET CHANGED.
GO, GO, GO, GO. GET CHANGED.
>> IT'S CRAZY BACKSTAGE.
IT'S, LIKE, PEOPLE
DRAGGING ME ONE WAY
AND THEN THEY TAKE ME
ANOTHER WAY.
>> BE CAREFUL.
>> PEOPLE ARE JUST
RUNNING AROUND,
TRYING TO GET DRESSED IN TIME.
IT'S JUST REALLY CRAZY.
>> HURRY. HURRY. LET'S GO.
WE'VE GOT ONE. WE'VE GOT ONE.
WE'VE GOT ONE.
ALL RIGHT, MOLLY,
LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK AT YOU
REAL FAST.
>> MY SECOND LAP
AROUND THE RUNWAY,
I'M FEELING
A LITTLE BIT MORE CONFIDENT.
>> MOLLY LOOKS GOOD.
>> I DEFINITELY KNOW
THAT I HAVE RHYTHM.
I CAN HEAR THE MUSIC
AND FEED OFF THAT.
>> YES, GIRL! WHOO!
>> WE'VE SEEN HER WALK
IN A RUNWAY SHOW,
BUT IT WAS NEVER LIKE THIS.
I MEAN, IT'S ALMOST LIKE,
WHO IS THAT CHILD?
AND SHE LOOKED BEAUTIFUL ANYWAY.
OUR BABY GIRL.
>> SHE DID.
>> SO LET'S JUST CHECK BRITTANI
OUT REAL QUICK, THEO.
ARE WE GOOD?
>> WHOO!
WORK!
>> OH!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE FEELING I GET
WHEN I DO RUNWAY,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW TO EXPLAIN IT.
IT'S JUST THAT ADRENALINE RUSH,
AND I FEEL SO GOOD
AND SO CONFIDENT.
>> THAT GIRL'S GOT SOMETHING.
>> I JUST--
I REALLY LOVE RUNWAY A LOT.
>> STEP THAT WAY.
>> THIS IS SUCH GREAT STYLING.
>> THE FINAL LAP IS
ME AND BRITTANI WALKING
SIDE BY SIDE.
>> HOLD IT FOR A WHILE THERE,
GIRLS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IT'S A LOT HARDER
POSING WITH ANOTHER PERSON
'CAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO DO.
>> WE GET IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES
AND WE'RE POSING,
BUT WE REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WE WERE DOING,
AND AT ONE POINT,
I STARTED LAUGHING, 'CAUSE,
LIKE, IT LOOKED LIKE
WE WERE IN SOME KIND OF,
LIKE, SEX POSITION.
>> BROKEN-DOWN DOLL.
>> MY HIPS ARE, LIKE,
ON THE BACK OF HER,
AND WE BOTH LOOK SILLY,
AND SHE JUST KINDA
STARTED TO GIGGLE.
>> ♪ AND I'M READY ♪
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THERE'S
THESE DAMN ROSE PETALS,
AND YOUR SHOES ARE SO SLIPPY,
LIKE, YOUR SHOE ALWAYS, LIKE,
KINDA GLIDES ON THEM.
>> (trilling)
(thud)
>> OH, NO.
>> MY GOD!
>> BRITTANI SLIPS
ON THE ROSE PETALS,
TRIES TO CATCH HERSELF, DOESN'T,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I PUT MY HAND OUT,
AND SHE GRABS MY HAND,
AND I HELP HER UP.
>> I'M JUST THINKING, LIKE,
WHAT DID I DO?
I REALLY JUST FREAKING FELL
DURING THE BIGGEST MOMENT
OF MY LIFE.
IT WASN'T ENOUGH THAT I FELL,
EXCEPT THAT MY (bleep) ANKLE
HURTS.
>> BRITTANI AND MOLLY, BACK OUT.
>> WE'RE DOING THIS AGAIN?
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN DO IT AGAIN.
I'M LIMPING,
AND THERE'S NO WAY
I CAN DO A RUNWAY WALK.
>> IT'S KILLING?
OKAY, WELL, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TRY AND PUSH THROUGH IT
IF YOU CAN.
>> SO WE'RE DOING THIS
ALL OVER AGAIN?
>> YEAH.
>> MY ANKLE
REALLY, REALLY HURTS.
>> SHE REALLY HURT HERSELF.
>> (crying) IT JUST SUCKS,
'CAUSE, LIKE, MY MOM'S NOT EVEN
HERE, AND THAT JUST REALLY,
SUCKS, 'CAUSE I WISH I COULD
TALK TO HER ABOUT ALL THIS
AND I CAN'T.
>> I FELL AND THEN MY NIGHT
WENT PRETTY MUCH DOWNHILL.
I SLIPPED ON ROSE PETALS,
AND I, LIKE, FELL,
AND I HAD TO
CATCH MYSELF WITH THE WALL,
AND THEN I CUT MY WRIST.
(sniffles) IT JUST SUCKS 'CAUSE,
LIKE, MY MOM'S NOT EVEN HERE,
AND THAT JUST REALLY SUCKS,
'CAUSE I WISH I COULD
TALK TO HER ABOUT THIS,
LIKE, AND I CAN'T.
>> YOU SLIPPED, YOU FELL,
YOU RECOVERED.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT IF YOU CAN MAKE--
IF YOU CAN MAKE IT
FOR THIS FINALE, WE'RE GOOD.
>> I REALLY DISAPPOINTED MYSELF.
LIKE, EVERYBODY THINKS
I'M REALLY GREAT AT RUNWAY,
AND THEN I'MTHE ONE THAT FALLS?
>> KEEP GOING. KEEP GOING.
>> THAT'S THE ONE TIME
I EVER REALLY GET UPSET--
WHEN I DISAPPOINT MYSELF.
>> (cheering)
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> VERY GOOD.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK, IVAN, YOU CAN
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THIS--
THIS IS PROBABLY
THE TIGHTEST COMPETITION
THAT WE'VE HAD.
I MEAN, I THINK YOU GUYS
FEEL IT, BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO KICK IT UP A LITTLE BIT MORE,
AND TYRA HAD THIS GREAT IDEA.
>> I THINK BOTH OF YOU
WOULD LOOK A LITTLE BIT MODERN
WITH A NEW LOOK.
>> (gasps)
>> WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A TOTALLY DIFFERENT LOOK
FOR PANEL,
YOU KNOW, THIS HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE ON "TOP MODEL."
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE BOTH NOW
OFFICIALLY MODELS.
>> OOH!
>> SO, YOU KNOW, YOU JUST
HAVE TO GO WITH THE FLOW.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WOW.
TWO BEAUTIFUL LADIES
THAT HAVE COME A LONG WAY,
THAT HAVE CUT THEIR LONG HAIR,
AND NOW HAVE
TWO OF MY FAVORITE HAIRCUTS.
YOU BOTH LOOK STUNNING.
AND YOU BOTH LOOK
VERY MARKETABLE,
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL GET
A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL SHOOT
A SPREAD
IN ITALIAN "VOGUE" MAGAZINE
AND A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN,
AND A 6-PAGE SPREAD
IN "BEAUTY IN VOGUE."
ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL BE FEATURED
ON vogue.it, WHICH IS
ITALIAN "VOGUE'S" WEB SITE.
AND ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL HAVE
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND MR. JAY MANUEL.
HE'S THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
LET'S GET STARTED.
>> SO YOU BOTH WALKED IN
A VIVIENNE WESTWOOD ANGLOMANIA
FASHION SHOW.
AND WE'RE GONNA EVALUATE
YOUR WALKS.
WE'LL START WITH YOU, BRITTANI.
>> YOU KNOW, BRITTANI,
ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I LOVED IS
THAT YOU STRUTTED OUT
ON THAT RUNWAY
WITH JUST CONFIDENCE.
>> YOU DID OWN IT.
AND YOU LOOKED CONFIDENT.
YOU WERE HAVING FUN.
A COUPLE OF TIMES,
YOU DROPPED OUT OF CHARACTER.
YOU GOTTA STAY IN THE MOMENT.
>> BIG LAUGH THAT YOU HAD
BECAUSE YOU HAD TO DOUBLE
WITH MOLLY.
IF SOMETHING WAS UNCOORDINATED,
I DIDN'T KNOW.
I COULDN'T EVEN TELL
UNTIL YOU BURST OUT INTO LAUGH.
THAT'S NOT COOL.
>> I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
BE COMMENDED ON THE FACT
THAT AFTER YOU DID
HAVE YOUR SPILL AND YOU FELL
AND YOU HURT YOURSELF,
YOU DID PUSH THROUGH THAT.
>> I ALSO LIKED
THAT YOU HAD AN URBAN WALK,
AS IF YOU WERE
RUSHING DOWN A STREET.
>> I THOUGHT THAT YOUR POSE
WAS DIVINE.
YOU WEREN'T TRYING TO, LIKE,
OVERSHADOW HER,
LIKE, "IT'S ALL ABOUT ME."
IT'S--YOU'RE, LIKE,
"I'M-A MELT INTO YOU,
BUT YOU GOTTA WORK WITH ME."
>> (laughs) YEAH.
>> AMAZING.
BUT I DON'T LIKE THAT
BREAKING OF THE LAUGH THING
AT ALL.
OKAY, MOLLY.
>> MOLLY, YOU HAD A GREAT WALK.
THERE'S A LITTLE SHAKE
THAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR WALK.
IT'S--I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S YOUR SIGNATURE THING,
BUT IT DOES MAKE IT LOOK
A LITTLE SORT OF CHEAP.
>> I THINK THE NERVES
JUST TOOK OVER,
AND YOU STARTED TO THINK
ABOUT THE WALK AS OPPOSED TO
RELYING ON YOUR CONFIDENCE
AND WHAT YOU'RE STRONG AT.
>> I NOTICED THE BOUNCE,
AND WHEN YOU WALKED AWAY,
I THOUGHT THE BOUNCE
WAS TOO MUCH OF A BOUNCE.
>> I LIKED YOUR WALK A LOT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO WORK
ON WHEN YOU PAUSE,
SMOOTHLY TRANSITION.
YOUR TRANSITIONS ARE
WHAT KINDA LOOK LIKE,
"HEY, GIRL! MM-HMM!
YEAH, GIRL!"
AND WE DON'T WANT THAT.
WE WANT HIGH FASHION.
YOU DID A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
SO HERE'S THEIR COMMERCIAL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> UNDENIABLY COLORFUL...
>> SERIOUSLY SMOOTH
AND IN EXCELLENT CONDITION...
>> THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
>> IT DOESN'T JUST GIVE YOU
BEAUTIFUL COLOR NOW,
IT GIVES YOU BEAUTIFUL LIPS
IN SEVEN DAYS.
>> IN A SINGLE STROKE,
RICH COLOR ROCKS YOUR LIPS.
>> IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
>> HOW PERFECT.
>> NEW LipPerfection
IN 44 LIP-PERFECTING SHADES...
>> FROM EASY...
>> BREEZY...
>> BEAUTIFUL...
>> COVERGIRL.
>> CUTE, RIGHT?
>> NOW WE'RE GOING TO SEE
YOUR BEST TAKES,
STARTING WITH BRITTANI.
(beep)
>> ACTION.
>> UNDENIABLY COLORFUL,
SERIOUSLY SMOOTH,
AND IN EXCELLENT CONDITION--
THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
IT DOESN'T JUST GIVE YOU
BEAUTIFUL COLOR NOW,
IT GIVES YOU BEAUTIFUL LIPS
IN SEVEN DAYS.
IN A SINGLE STROKE,
RICH COLOR ROCKS YOUR LIPS.
IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
HOW PERFECT.
NEW LipPerfection
IN 44 LIP-PERFECTING SHADES,
FROM EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
>> BRITTANI, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I LOVE ABOUT YOU IS
YOUR UNBELIEVABLE TWO PROFILES.
YOU'RE--YOU'RE SMILING
WITH ONE SIDE OF YOUR FACE,
WHILE LOOKING ALMOST SEXY
AND HALF-SMIRKING
WITH THE OTHER.
>> THE ASYMMETRY OF YOUR FACE
THAT WORKS AMAZING.
>> I DO AGREE WITH NIGEL
ABOUT THE ANGLES,
AND I LOVE THE PR--SIDE VIEWS.
>> WHEN YOU STEPPED ON SET,
YOU WERE BUBBLY
AND YOU WERE PERFECT.
YOU WERE SO EASY TO DIRECT,
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T LET
ANYTHING BOTHER YOU
AT THAT MOMENT,
AND THAT'S AN IMPRESSIVE QUALITY
TO HAVE.
>> NOW WE'RE GOING TO WATCH
MOLLY'S BEST TAKE
FOR HER COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
(beep)
>> ACTION.
>> UNDENIABLY COLORFUL,
SERIOUSLY SMOOTH,
AND IN EXCELLENT CONDITION--
THOSE ARE YOUR LIPS WITH
NEW COVERGIRL LipPerfection.
IT DOESN'T JUST GIVE YOU
BEAUTIFUL COLOR NOW,
IT GIVES YOU BEAUTIFUL LIPS
IN SEVEN DAYS.
IN A SINGLE STROKE,
RICH COLOR ROCKS YOUR LIPS.
IN A SINGLE WEEK,
SILK THERAPY MOISTURIZERS
HELP SMOOTH AND SOFTEN THEM.
HOW PERFECT.
NEW LipPerfection
IN 44 LIP-PERFECTING SHADES
FROM EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
>> MEAN GIRL.
I GOT A MEAN GIRL.
I GOT A GORGEOUS GIRL,
BUT SHE'S, LIKE, "YEAH,
AND YOU WISH YOU LOOKED
AS GOOD AS ME, BUT YOU DON'T."
>> IT JUST ISN'T COVERGIRL.
COVERGIRL IS AN INVITING YOU.
YOU CAN ALL BE A COVERGIRL.
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> I ONLY WISH THAT
YOUR HAIR HAD BEEN SHORN
BEFORE YOU DID THE COMMERCIAL,
BECAUSE NOW, STANDING HERE,
YOU'RE VERY, VERY FRESH.
>> BUT THE THING
THAT THE JUDGES DON'T KNOW
IS YOU READ THE ENTIRE SCRIPT
TO ME FROM MEMORY.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I LOOK FOR
AS A POSITIVE QUALITY IN A GIRL.
YOU ABSORBED IT,
AND IT WAS SO CHARMING.
>> YOU GUYS ALSO DID
AND AD FOR COVERGIRL.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT,
BRITTANI.
>> STUNNING.
BEAUTIFUL.
A LITTLE STARTLED.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY BRILLIANT.
THE ONLY FLAW I SEE IS
THE HAND ON THE LEFT IS
A BIT TOO HEAVY.
>> WITH COVERGIRL,
ESPECIALLY NOW,
THEY'RE FRESHY, SASSIER,
HAVING A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF THAT EDGE,
AND I ASKED YOU TO BRING THAT
TO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU DEFINITELY DID.
>> THIS PICTURE IS
VERY STUNNING.
WHEN YOU ARE MODELING COSMETICS,
YOU HAVE TO PUT
EVERY OUNCE OF ENERGY
INTO WHATEVER BODY PART
THE PRODUCT IS APPLIED TO.
SO IF IT'S EYES,
IT HAS TO BE... (grunts)
IF IT'S LIPS, THEN YOU HAVE
TO... (grunts)
IF IT'S... (grunts)
AND I FEEL LIKE
I WANT THAT LIPSTICK.
MOLLY, ARE YOU READY
FOR YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> I GOTTA SAY,
THE WAY THE LIGHT'S
HITTING YOUR FACE
IS STUNNING.
YOU LOOK SUPER BEAUTIFUL,
IT'S SOFT, IT'S GENTLE.
>> YOU KNOW, MOLLY,
I LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU COMMITTED TO IT.
IT REALLY HELPED DELIVER
THIS IMAGE.
>> MOLLY, IT'S WONDERFUL.
THIS IS TO BE FRAMED
AND PUT IN THE SALON.
>> (chuckles)
YOU HAVE, LIKE, A LITTLE BIT
OF A TIGER-ESQUE THING.
IT'S THIS KIND OF ENCHANTING
KIND OF DANGER,
BUT NOT INTIMIDATING.
>> "LET'S GET TO KNOW HER."
YEAH, THEY WANT
TO BE HER FRIEND.
>> YEAH.
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WE WILL CONSIDER
YOUR ENTIRE BODY OF WORK,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHO IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, LADIES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE.
WE HAVE TWO LOVELY GIRLS,
AND THEY BOTH VERY MUCH WANT
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THE BEE SHOOT.
I LOVED THE LONG NECKS.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
BRITTANI'S NECK IN HERE
IS ALMOST ALIEN-LIKE.
>> LIKE A HORSE.
>> AND I GOTTA SAY,
I DO THINK THAT MOLLY'S PROFILE
IS EXTRAORDINARY HERE.
>> I THINK MOLLY NATURALLY HAS
THAT "TOP MODEL" "IT" FACTOR.
>> I THINK THAT BRITTANI--
SHE SOMEHOW MANAGES
TO TURN HERSELF INTO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT EVERY TIME,
AND IT'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL
AND IT'S A SURPRISE.
>> COULD WE TALK ABOUT
MOLLY ON TOP OF THE CAMEL?
>> THAT IS GORGEOUS.
>> I MEAN, THAT DAY,
I MEAN, I WAS LIVING
FOR THIS MOMENT FROM MOLLY
ON TOP THE CAMEL.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT MOLLY
ON TOP OF THE ROCK,
SHOT BY MR. BARKER?
>> YOU KNOW, MOLLY IS
THE ONE FOR ME
WHEN IT COMES TO BODY MOVEMENT
AND SHAPES.
>> SHE LOOKED STUNNING TODAY
IN THE SHOW
IN THAT RED DRESS.
AND LET'S JUST GIVE BRITTANI
THE--THE--THE TOTAL APPLAUSE
FOR HAVING CRASHED
INTO THE FLOOR--
THE MARBLE FLOOR IN THE RIAD--
AND THEN CAME BACK OUT
IN THE FINALE,
SMILING AND CLAPPING
AS IF NOTHING HAD HAPPENED.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW
THE GIRL WAS IN PAIN.
I HAD NO IDEA.
>> HER FOOT STARTED SWELLING UP.
WE HAD TO TAKE THE SHOE OFF.
I MEAN, IT WAS--IT WAS CRAZY.
>> LOOKING AT THE PORTFOLIOS,
I'VE GOTTA SAY,
MOLLY IS NOT
YOUR CONVENTIONAL BLONDE.
THERE'S A REAL NATURAL FLOW
TO THE PORTFOLIO.
>> BRITTANI JUST GIVES YOU
THE FRESHNESS AND THE CHARM.
>> THE CROOKED SMILE
IS SO ATTRACTIVE,
IT'S SOENDEARING.
>> THE MODELING INDUSTRY IS
OBSESSED WITH SYMMETRY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> I THINK SHE'S A GOOD EXAMPLE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
IF SHE WERE TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT... (grunts)
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT THERE'S
THIS WACKINESS,
THERE'S WEIRDNESS,
THERE'S UNIQUENESS
THAT IS ACTUALLY BEAUTIFUL.
>> THE ONE GREAT THING
ABOUT MOLLY IS
YOU LOOK AT THE CLOTHES
THAT SHE HAS IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THIS FIRST WEEK WITH MOLLY,
WITH THAT HAIR FLINGING...
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS LIKE, "O.M.G."
>> YES.
>> LOVE. PAMELA HANSON.
>> THE FACT THAT BRITTANI
GOT INTO THE CHARACTER,
I THINK, BROUGHT THE PHOTO
TO LIFE,
WHEREAS MOLLY JUST WAS LIKE,
"OKAY, SHOOT ME IN THIS HAT."
>> BRITTANI'S WEARING THE HAT,
AND THE HAT IS WEARING MOLLY.
I DID A REALLY QUICK,
QUICK, QUICK PHOTO SHOOT.
I DID THEIR HAIR
AND THEIR MAKEUP...
>> OH, LET ME SEE.
I DIDN'T SEE THEM.
>> UH, THE PHOTOGRAPHY.
>> BRITTANI HERE IS
EXTRAORDINARY--
THE EMOTIONAL SOUL
IN HER PICTURES.
MOLLY, FOR ME, IS HARD,
UH, BEAUTIFUL--
>> LOOK AT THE--HOW THE LIGHT
SITS ON MOLLY'S FACE.
I THINK IF PEOPLE WERE
TO LOOK AT THIS SHOT,
I THINK THEY WOULD GRAVITATE
TO BOOKING HER
BECAUSE THEY JUST THINK
SHE JUST LOOKS
YOUNG AND NEW AND NOW.
>> AND SO DOES BRITTANI.
>> BRITTANI'S ROMANTIC.
>> I AGREE. BRITTANI'S ROMANTIC.
IT'S JUST THAT SOFTER LOOK
IN HER FACE.
>> BUT MOLLY HAS BEEN NAILING IT
WITH HOW MANY
BEST PHOTOS OF THE WEEK?
>> THREE.
>> THREE IN A ROW.
>> YOU KNOW THOSE MAGAZINES
WHEN YOU HAVE, UH, TWO COVERS--
ONE COVER ON THE BACK,
ONE ON THE FRONT,
AND BOTH ARE GREAT?
>> BUT THEY TYPICALLY
ONLY PREFER ONE
TO FLIP HER FORWARD, THOUGH.
>> WE HAVE MADE A DECISION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THE TIME HAS COME.
THE JUDGES HAVE DELIBERATED...
>> AND...
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
IS...
>> BRITTANI!
>> (crying)
>> CAN'T BELIEVE IT?
>> I LOST.
I WANTED THIS REALLY BADLY,
AND I FAILED AT THE ONE THING
THAT I WANTED TO DO.
>> THIS HURTS, RIGHT?
REJECTION?
BIT IT DOESN'T MAKE US STOP.
IT'S GONNA KNOCK YOU DOWN,
YOU'RE GONNA GET YOUR CRY IN,
AND THEN YOU'RE JUST
GONNA WAKE UP AND SAY,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BUT I CAN STILL BE A MODEL,
AND I CAN STILL BE
VERY, VERY SUCCESSFUL."
OKAY?
>> I'M HAPPY FOR BRITTANI.
YOU KNOW, I WISH HER THE BEST.
THE FIRST THING I DO
WHEN I GET HOME IS
I'M GOING TO TAKE A NAP,
AND I'M GOING TO EAT
A PULLED PORK SANDWICH.
>> THINK ABOUT IT.
GIRL FROM THE TRAILER PARK...
>> IS A COVERGIRL...
>> OH, AND--
>> AND AN IMG MODEL.
MY MOM--OH, MY GOD.
WHEN SHE FINDS OUT THAT I WON,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT SHE'LL DO.
>> AND NOW YOU'RE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE ON THE COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE"?
>> I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE IT.
>> AND NOW IT'S UP TO YOU
TO TAKE THAT AND JUST...
(makes whooshing sound)
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE YOU'RE FROM
OR HOW YOU'RE RAISED
OR WHAT YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
IF YOU JUST PUT YOUR MIND TO IT.
I WAS REALLY CLOSE TO GIVING UP,
AND IT JUST PROVES
DON'T EVER DO THAT,
BECAUSE RIGHT WHENEVER
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GIVE UP,
SOMETHING GREAT
REALLY, REALLY HAPPENS.
>> OOH! LOOK AT THOSE EYES!
>> YES! YES!
>> WHOO!
WORK.
>> I'M A COVERGIRL
AND I'M AN IMG MODEL,
AND EVERYTHING I'VE EVER DONE
HAS FINALLY PAID OFF.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.